another darker version of your question
is
if we keep all the material possessions
we have but we start
knocking out some percent of the
population
how resilient is the system that we
built up or if we rely on other humans
and the knowledge of built up on the
past the distribute the
distributed nature of knowledge
how
how much does it take how many humans
need to disappear
for us to be completely lost
well i'm trying to go off one thing
which is um elon musk says that
he has this number a million in mind as
the order of ma or magnitude of people
you need to
be on mars to truly be multi-planetary
yeah multi-planetary doesn't mean you
know
uh
like
when when neil armstrong you know goes
to the moon that's they call it a great
leap for mankind yeah it's not a great
leap for anything it is a
great achievement for mankind and i
always like think about
if the first fish to kind of
go on land just kind of went up and gave
the shore high five and goes back into
the water that's not a great leap for
life that's a great achievement for that
fish and there should be a little statue
of that fish and it's you know in the
water and everyone
should celebrate the fish but it's um
but we talk about a great leap for life
it's permanent it's something that now
from now on this is how things are so
this is part of why i get so excited
about mars by the way is because you can
count on one hand like the number of
great leaps that we've had you know like
no life to life and single cell or
simple cell to complex cell and
single cell organisms to animals to come
you know multi-cell animals um
and then ocean to land and then
one planet to two planets anyway
diversion but the point is that um
we are officially that leap for all of
life you know has happened once
the ships could stop coming from earth
because there's some horrible
catastrophic world war iii and everyone
dies on earth and they're fine and they
can turn that certain x number of people
into seven billion
you know population that's thriving just
like earth they can build ships that can
come back and recolonize earth because
now we are officially multi-planetary
where it's a self-sustaining he says a
million people is about what he thinks
now that might be a specialized group
that's that's a very specifically you
know selected million that has
um very very skilled million people not
just maybe the average million on earth
but i think it depends what you're
talking about but i don't think you know
so one million is one seven thousand one
eight thousandth of the current
population i think you need a very very
very small fraction
of humans on earth to get by obviously
you're not going to have the same
thriving civilization if you get to a
too small a number but it depends who
you're killing off i guess is part of
the question yeah
if you killed all half of the people
just randomly right now i think we'd be
fine it would be obviously a great awful
tragedy um i think if you killed off
three quarters of all people randomly
just three out of every four people
drops dead i think we'd have obviously
the stock market would crash uh we'd
have a rough patch but um i almost can
assure you that the species would be
fine well because the million number you
like you said it is specialized
so
i i think um
because you have to do this you have to
basically do the iphone experiment like
literally you have to be able to be able
to manufacture computers yeah everything
if you're going to have the
self-sustaining means you can you can
you know any major important skill any
important piece of inverse you know kind
of infrastructure on earth can be built
there in this you know just as well
it'd be interesting to uh
list out what are the important things
what are the important skills yeah i
mean if you have to feed everyone so you
know mass farming things like that um
you have to um you have to you have
mining these questions it's like
the materials might be i don't know i
don't know five mile two miles
underground i don't know what the actual
but like
it's amazing to me just that these
things got built in the first place and
you know they never got no one built the
first the mine that we're getting uh
stuff for the iphone for probably wasn't
built for the iphone you know or in
general early mining you know was for
you know i think obviously i assume the
industrial revolution when we realized
oh fossil fuels we want to extract this
magical energy source i assume that like
manny took a huge leap without knowing
very much about this i think you know
you're gonna need you need
mining you're gonna need like a lot of
electrical engineers if you're gonna
have a civilization like ours and of
course you could have oil and lanterns
we could go way back but if you're
trying to build our today thing you're
gonna need
uh you know energy and electricity and
then and mines that can bring materials
and then you're gonna need a ton of
plumbing and everything that entails
yeah and like you said food but also the
manufacturer so like turning raw
materials into something useful yeah
that whole thing like factories
some supply chain transportation
right you know i mean you think about
when we talk about the world hunger one
of the major problems is
you know there's plenty of food and by
the time it arrives most of it's gone
bad in the truck you know in in a kind
of an impoverished place so it's like
you know we take again we take it so for
granted all the food in the in the
supermarket is fresh it's all there and
which always stresses me if i were
running a supermarket i would always be
so like miserable about like
things going bad on the shelves um or if
you don't have enough that's not good
but if you have too much it goes bad
anyway of course there would be
entertainers too
like somebody would uh have a youtube
channel that's running on mars
there is something
different about a civilization on mars
and earth
existing versus like a civilization in
the united states versus russia and
china like that that's a different
fundamentally different distance
like yeah philosophically the quest will
it be like fuzzy we know there'll be
like a reality show on mars that
everyone on earth is obsessed with and
you know if i think if people are going
back and forth
enough then it becomes fuzzy it becomes
like oh our friend's on mars and there's
like this mars versus earth you know
like you know and it become like fun
tribalism uh i think if people don't
rarely go back and forth and it really
they're there for i think it could get
kind of like oh we hate you know a lot
of like us versus them stuff going on
there could be also war in space for
territory
as uh first colony happens
china russia or whoever the european
different european nations switzerland
finally gets their act together and
starts wars this is supposed to be
staying out yeah all kinds of crazy
geopolitical things that like we have
not even
no one's really even thought about too
much yet that like it could get weird
think about the 1500s
when it was suddenly like a race to like
you know colonize or capture land or
discover new land that hasn't been you
know so it was like this this new
frontiers and there's not really you
know the land is not you know the thing
about crimea was like this huge thing
because this tiny peninsula switched
that's how like
optimized everything has become
everything is just like really stuck
mars is a whole new world of like you
know territory fighting for naming
things and you know
um
and it's a chance for new kind of
governments maybe or maybe it's just the
colonies of these governments so we
don't get that opportunity i think it'd
be cool if this new country is being you
know totally new experiments yeah and
that's fascinating because elon talks
exactly about that and i i believe that
very much like that should be
like from from the start they should
determine their own
sovereignty like they
they should determine their own thing
there was one modern democracy in the
late 1700s the u.s i mean it was the
only
modern democracy and now
of course that's there's there's
hundreds or doesn't many dozens but i
think part of the reason that was able
to start i mean it's not the people
didn't have the idea people had the idea
it was that it was the head of clean
slate new place you know and they
suddenly were you know so i think it's
it would be a great opportunity to have
there's a lot of people have done that
you know oh if i had my own government
on an island my own country what would i
do and it's the the u.s founders
actually
had the opportunity that fantasy they
were like we can do it let's make okay
what's the perfect country and they
tried to make something um sometimes
progress is
it's not held up by our imagination it's
held up by just there's no
you know blank canvas to try something
on
yeah it's an opportunity for fresh start
you know the funny thing about the
conversation we're having is not often
had
i mean even by elon he's so focused on
starship and actually putting the first
human on mars
i think
thinking about this kind of stuff
is um
inspiring it makes his dream it makes us
hope for the future so
and it makes us somehow like thinking
about civilization on mars is um
helping us think about the civilization
here on earth yeah how we should run it
what do you think are like in our
lifetime are we gonna i think any effort
that goes to mars
the goal is in this decade do you think
uh that's actually gonna be achieved i
have a big bet ten thousand dollars with
a friend uh when i was drunk uh okay in
an argument um
right that the the neil armstrong of
mars whoever he or she may be will set
foot
by the end of 2030.
now this was probably 2018 when i had
this argument so like what a human has
to touch mars by 20 and by the end of 20
30. oh by the year 30 yeah by january
1st 2031. yeah so
um did you agree on the time zone or
would you no no yeah it's coming on that
exact day that's going to be really
stressful but um
but anyway i i think that there will be
that was 2018 i was more confident then
um i think it's going to be around this
time i mean i still won the general bet
because his point was you are crazy this
is not going to happen in our lifetimes
or not for many many decades and i said
you're wrong you don't know what's going
on in spacex i think if the world
depended on it and i think probably
spacex could probably i mean i don't
know this but
i think the tech is almost there like i
don't think of course it's it's delayed
many years by safety so they first want
to send a ship you know around mars and
they want to land a cargo ship on mars
and there's the moon on the way too yeah
yeah there's there's a lot but i think
the moon
a decade before seemed like magical tech
that we that humans didn't have this is
like no
we we can
it's it is it's totally conceivable that
this you've seen starship like it's
um
it is a
interplanetary colonial or
interplanetary transport like system
that's what they used to call it
the spacex the way they do it is every
time they do a launch something fails
usually you know uh when they're testing
and they learn a thousand things the
amount of data they get and they improve
so each one has it's you know it's like
they've moved up like eight generations
in each one anyway so
it's not inconceivable that pretty soon
they could send a starship to mars and
land it uh there's just no good reason i
don't think that they couldn't do that
and so if they could do that they could
in theory send a person to mars pretty
soon now taking off for mars and coming
back again i think i don't think anyone
want to be on that voyage today because
there's just you know they're still in
it's still amateur hour here yeah and
getting that perfect
i don't think we're too far away now the
question is
so every so every 26
months earth laps mars right it's like
the sinocidal soil or orbit or whatever
it's called the period 26 months
so it's right now like in the evens like
2022 is gonna have one of these 2020
late 2024 so people could this was the
earliest estimate i heard elon said
maybe we can send people to mars in 2024
you know to land in 2020 early 2025.
that is not going to happen because that
that included 2022 sending a cargo ship
to mars uh maybe even a one in 2020 and
so i think they're not quite on that
schedule but to win my bet uh 2027 i
have a chance in 2029 i have another
chance nice we're not very good at like
backing up and seeing the big picture
we're very distracted by what's going on
today and what's what we can believe
because it's happening in front of our
face there's no way that humans gonna be
landing on mars and it's not gonna be
the only thing everyone is talking about
right i mean it's gonna it's it's gonna
be the moon landing but even bigger deal
going to another planet right and and
for to start a colony not just again
high five and come back
so this is like
the 2020s maybe the 2030s
is going to be the new 1960s we're gonna
have a space decade i'm so excited about
it yeah and it's again it's one of the
great leaps for all of life happening in
our lifetimes like that's wild
you